[Música]
[Aplausos]
empezamos
después
[Música]
posteriormente más
y después mi colección
y
cada una de las presentaciones de una
manera
[ __ ]
a los 56 años mi padre a conocer el
continente
y
y entonces
[Música]
si eres
d
nuestras dos estaban las dos hermanas en
un sillón
y el sábado verdad
versiones de cómo se relacionan
de su comunidad necesitan después
llegaron
es de agradecer el técnico cuando fue a
la organización es
en esa zona se parece a no decir
[Música]
actualmente
y así ha sido
por ejemplo
te quiero
y
[Música]
y me trajeron a la primera estación que
como
esta mañana
la gente a veces teníamos el ambiente
y es esa
años después
la sensación de llegar a ese tratamiento
desde 2
como unidades
[Música]
tiene discusión
todo
[Música]
cuando confirman estas dos velas
i
cuenta
[Música]
por dios
me siento bien
después de una hora de trabajo
cuando nosotros llegamos porque sí
también en vitoria liberando las
elecciones mexicanas
este es el verdadero
después
[Música]
viene
más
es social
tarde
de qué se trata y en esta materia y
gestionables convenios para ella
[Música]
y realmente utilizan a los tiene se
cansaba sondeando mejorando
el fuego y fue devolviendo
[Música]
es normal
d
y vamos a decir
[Música]
la biblioteca
o sea
mejor es así
el dinero más fácil
[Música]
me acuerdo bien y se lo digo por qué
se inició
nosotros bueno su padre
y
y la historia
y se lo dejan en eso
y no ha existido en la historia podía
empezar de verdad
muchísimas
y ciertamente tenemos agendado
descontaron detenidos
i
[Música]
en su momento vamos esposa
las cosas que tenemos entonces también
es sencillo
ojo con sabor a lo que ya nos tiene que
ser francia o sector
mientras que la televisión también
[Música]
cómo
esta vez
buscando
cómo está el resultado
es decir
bien
pues estas tierras
hasta dicen del otro
o más bien el menor
sin mirar
como porque tenemos que estar de paso
hacer esa comunicación verbal
qué buena buena
nos miramos
de chile
de las mujeres con hijos en este sitio
pero miren
y aquellos que no están dispuestos a
esperar
de un metro
y los coches
también profundo a los otros
y la formación de las cosas
los electores ponemos lugar entraba en
un motor
y os vimos lo que esta persona sea
inferior a la nacional
y creo que vamos a tener
esto
no porque siendo tecnología que estamos
porque estábamos
as
y en nuestras carreras más serias
y vamos a hacer
[Música]
y
primero es la investigación se
desarrolla
al interior de los meses
una universidad de comunicaciones de
unos meses
y valores
[Música]
tiene
muchísimo es necesario
y permanentemente habrá resultados
quieren vender
forma de universidad es una razón de ser
para que no hemos salido hasta oponerse
anteriores es el momento de modificar
es
investigar de acción
en el ciclo de los normales
pero no
y es creces todos
es decir las comunidades entonces
vamos a empezar por estos errores
donde universidad de lo que está
tratando de trabajar
gente
y entonces pero se compra en realidad es
que está séptimo
[Música]
hay descripciones
después de semana
s
como investigadores universitarios de
intenciones
entonces nos llegue decir de acuerdo
esto es erróneo
y viernes
no me han decidido para 2003 antes pero
por qué vas a perder
y entonces en escamas y los otros
estados
[Música]
después
cuando después de la gente también ha
analizado este servidor
este proyecto de dos años de crecimiento
para besar hacer
y entonces no es posible
[Música]
sabe que el monje de los jóvenes
es ud
personas trabajando
y entonces
[Música]
entonces no está bien
y entonces
y ese partido puede pasar
y es que no debe ser como antes
y utilizarla me cambia de forma básica
de forma usted
entonces para nosotros
no más
y van der sar
es decir
las comidas
vélez
y dos porque creo en eso
[Música]
yo
es como decir a torácico de la lengua
[Música]
sin partidismos
así es
de verdad
e
además hace tres cuatro meses parecen
oportunas
y entonces
[Aplausos]
así
[Música]
muchas veces
[Aplausos]